this week our friend mike nena which is
a name that will be familiar to many of
you he is a documentary filmmaker
uh he made among other things the um
he
he documented the grievance studies
affair with peter pagosian and helen
blecros and james lindsey and he also
produced
directed created all of it uh the three
part one and a half hour total evergreen
documentary uh which he sort of came to
know uh as
as as we met him back when we did it
actually i guess we met him when we did
a
an event
we met him and peter burgosian and helen
blecros and james lindsey and james
damore all at the same event uh where uh
four of us were on stage and you
introduced us and
all this at uh portland state university
back in
spring of 2018 something like that so i
just want to add what i believe happened
was he was going to use evergreen as an
example in his documentary on uh
the um the so-called squared hoax the
studies the grievance studies affair
yeah
and
as we told him would happen if you dig
into the evergreen story a little bit
you're going to fall into this
incredible rabbit hole of absurdity and
that's in fact what happened and so he
did a separate little documentary on
evergreen not that little yeah it's not
that little three-part it's totally if
you haven't seen it it's totally worth
it you'll understand things about about
this and you know it's also a good time
capsule because it was several years
back
um but anyway he also uh participated
extensively with benjamin boyce in
putting that together a lot of the
footage there are things that benjamin
boyce collected cataloged um and uh you
know pried loose from
evergreen in benjamin the swayer
requests that just wouldn't stop right
and so benjamin has done an incredible
job of
getting all of the material that
explains that event into the world so
anyway check out benjamin voice and mike
nina on youtube uh there's a whole world
of fascinating stuff yeah
so mike has become a friend we haven't
seen well anything of him in the last
two years of course but we haven't seen
much of him
um but he saw our clip uh on what we
understood to be happening in australia
and he wrote he wrote to us at some
length and we had a little back and
forth and i'm going to post his entire
letter to us on my substance next
tuesday that's going to be my tuesday
post but um and you know
i asked him
you know what degree he wanted
to be anonymized and he said you don't
need to anonymize me at all i think this
is important to have in the world but
you know he says these are just some
things i've seen you know these are just
some things that i've jotted down about
what i've experienced being in australia
because australian uh since since this
all began
so he says
heather's analogy to the reporters
covering the portland riots in late 2020
is close to how i see it too
while gathering personal stories and
perspectives on the ground it becomes
clear that experiences differ from state
to state from suburb to suburb and even
house to house there's something absurd
in trying to describe it all in
monolithic terms australians are dot dot
dot
some things that have stuck with me
though he says include
i saw a man in a canoe stopped by a
police boat
i was i was pulled over by two policemen
on motorbikes sirens and all for having
my nose sticking out at the top of my
mask it was a sunny day and i was alone
for at least 300 meters in all
directions
they were not polite
it was illegal for me to see my family
for the better part of a year even
outdoors
because they lived outside of a
permitted zone
my sister was home alone with two boys
aged four and sex for around eight
months while her husband was stuck in
africa
we had to obtain a doctor's letter to
visit her
when i'd arrived she'd burst out of the
house as if she were escaping something
a friend went for a run was stopped by
police they checked her id and asked
what she was doing she said she was
exercising two hours later she got home
and they were waiting to find her for
exceeding the time limit for permitted
exercise
he's got a lot more again which i'll
post on natural selections on tuesday
yesterday mike sent another note as
follows
one more thing you might find
interesting and to keep you up to date
is that it's summer now on the east
coast of australia is at long last
moving from a zero covered paradigm into
a mitigation model my sense from talking
to family and looking at their instagram
feeds is that lives are looking a little
more normal and memories of the police
state are beginning to fade
i'm sure many like myself saw something
they don't want to forget so quickly and
are unsettled by the state's capacity to
flick the switch like they did
terrifying
so
terrifying and as we said in the
original clip which he was
referring to um which he was responding
to
it does feel like there will be people
who will say i'm in australia and
that's not true
and what they mean is i'm in australia
and i didn't see any of those things
and that's
possible of course
in some of these cases only mike and say
those police officers are the ones who
saw it right
but the idea that you will generalize
a perfect you know pseudo-utopian
democratic state from not having
directly experienced things yourself
especially
if you have the kinds of privilege that
many of the voices out of australia who
are claiming that nothing is amiss there
have
is
rather the opposite assumption that you
should have these examples
in this case from a trusted friend we
know he is not making any of these up
do provide evidence that something has
been very much a mess
they do not speak to
overall
pattern we don't know how many incidents
there were like any of those but one
person alone
a person with a trained eye who is who
is experienced in documenting things saw
a number of things across a number of
domains that were very much a mess did
not remind him of the country uh that he
calls home yeah we i think the thing we
really can't infer is how patchy it is
but the fact says that right differs
from suburb to suburb house to house but
the fact that one person observed all of
these things says something really
dramatic and i would point out i've been
thinking an awful lot about julian
assange uh in light of his uh
losing his
motion to stave off extradition
and
it increasingly is clear to me that
you know i mean
i was
vocal
at the beginning of the assange affair
and
i don't think i was vocal enough because
i think the point is it was very hard to
make the case that this is the step onto
the slippery slope that leads somewhere
you will find impossible to believe
right we are now somewhere that many of
us find impossible to believe and the
point is julian assange was the canary
in the coal mine and the absurd
treatment that he faced and the false
portrayal that has been so relentless
was a clear indication that something
wanted
rights to do this to a journalist that
embarrassed it right
this journalist did journalism
and
the the rights that no a person normally
has now he's not an american citizen so
in some technical sense he
lacks certain rights that he might
otherwise have but nonetheless something
clearly wanted to
uh
turn him into a political prisoner
torture him publicly so that we could
all watch him come apart so that others
wouldn't
wouldn't dare to do the same sort of
thing and we now have some indication of
why and no doubt the thing didn't know
about uh covet and in what context it
would abuse all of our rights but it did
know that it wanted the right to abuse
all of us and abusing all of us is a lot
easier with julian assange you know in a
cell somewhere and so anyway this is a
lesson of history that
i think we need to remind ourselves of
that you have to you have to prote
protest these things when they show up
at first because by the time it becomes
clear just how important and broad broad
the the threat is it it's too late you
know you're behind the eight ball at
that point
that's right
um
and it's even more important to protest
the things that are being done to
children
because what gets laid down in childhood
becomes very difficult if not impossible
to change
so we risk
destroying an entire generation
we do and uh
the reasons that you know the
the willingness the indifference to the
well-being of children that this
obviously illustrates
is spectacular and then there's a
question about why why they would do
this right
um and anyway it's something we should
revisit
[Music]
you